[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
ganz besonderen blechkuchen wir machen
pudding creme schnitten die einzelnen
schichten bestehen aus zwei leckeren
biscuit böden außerdem einem
selbstgekochten vanillepudding einer
unglaublich leckeren marshmallows
schicht und abgeschlossen mit das ganze
dann mit schokolade und schokoraspeln
nun starten wir aber zuallererst mit der
zubereitung der leckeren bizkit böden
das rezept das habe ich insgesamt
zweimal genommen denn ist es schwierig
den dünnen boden durchzuschneiden
wir benötigen eier zucker mehl
backpulver neutrales öl mineralwasser
mit kohlensäure vanillezucker oder
vanille extrakt und etwas salz
zuallererst werden die eier zusammen mit
der prise salz und dem zucker in der
küchenmaschine etwa fünf minuten lang
cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
nachdem die masse dann richtig schön
hell cremig geworden ist und das
doppelte an volumen zugenommen hat geben
wir die flüssigen zutaten mit hinein
einmal das wasser das nehme ich immer
gerne mit kohlensäure das macht den teig
ein wenig lockerer und das neutrale öl
ich habe hier sonnenblumenöl verwendet
ihr könnt an sonst noch gerne rapsöl
verwenden
nachdem das ganz kurz mit untergerührt
wurde gebe ich hier an der stelle noch
mein vanille extrakt mit dazu wer
vanillezucker verwenden möchte der kann
es auch ganz am anfang mit hinzugeben
dann wenn ja auch den weißen zucker mit
dazu gibt
nun geben wir nur noch die trockenen
zutaten mit hinein also mehl und
backpulver und damit keine klümpchen
entstehen sie mich das ganze vorher noch
und rühre dass dann so lange unter bis
es sich verbunden hat
[Musik]
den vorbereiteten teig geben wir dann
auf ein mit backpapier ausgelegtes
backblech
den bug rahmen müsst ihr nicht unbedingt
mit dazu geben aber dann habt ihr einen
schönen abschluss jetzt gebe ich den
teig darauf verteilt das schön glatt mit
der winkel palette und dann kommt er
auch schon in den ofen
[Musik]
der wird bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für ca 12 minuten gebacken das ganze
wiederholen wir dann so dass wir zwei
biscuit böden erhalten und lassen sie
vollständig auskühlen für die super
leckere fluffige weiße marshmallow
schicht benötigen wir puderzucker eiweiß
macht euch bei dem eiweiss keine sorgen
wir erhitzen das gleich noch und ein
wenig backpulver in meinem kopf habe ich
ein wenig wasser zum kochen gebracht und
gebe da jetzt eine ausreichend große
schüssel darüber gebe dann puderzucker
und das eiweiß mit hinzu
[Musik]
nun muss das ganze von anfang an ständig
mit dem schneebesen umgerührt werden das
heißt lasst es nicht aus den augen und
rührt fleißig um bis sich alles
miteinander verbunden hat sobald ihr die
masse nämlich für ein paar sekunden
nicht umrührt stock das ei und es kann
gut möglich sein dass ihr dann rührei
erhaltet nun gebe ich nach ca 2 minuten
auch das backpulver mit hinzu und rühre
dass weitere fünf minuten fleißig um
insgesamt habe ich die masse sieben
minuten lang auf dem herd erhitzt und
ihr seht auch dass das ein wenig
cremiger wird und ein wenig an wohnungen
zunimmt hier habt ihr jetzt keine gefahr
mehr dass ihr irgendwelche salmonellen
habe das ganze ist jetzt komplett frei
davon
und wir gehen rüber an die
küchenmaschine
die heiße masse kommt jetzt in meine
schüssel und dann werde ich das mit dem
schneebesen aufsatz etwa zehn minuten
lang schön steif schlagen
das gesamte rezept geht übrigens auch
ohne küchenmaschine und zwar mit dem
handrührgerät dann dauert das ganze ein
wenig länger aber es klappt auf jeden
fall also macht euch nichts draus wenn
ihr statt der küchenmaschine neuer
handrührgerät verwendet
[Musik]
nach zehn minuten erhaltet ihr diese
absolut fluffige und leckere weiße
cremige masse für die vanillepudding
schicht benötigen wir milch die übrig
gebliebenen eigelbe speisestärke zucker
und vanille extrakt oder vanilleschoten
oder auch gerne vanillezucker
zuallererst verrühren wir die eigelbe
zusammen mit der speisestärke und ein
wenig milch in einer separaten schüssel
die restliche milch gebe ich in den
kochtopf und lassen sie zusammen mit dem
zucker und dem vanille extrakt aufkochen
ich rate euch hier in aller erster linie
zu vanille extrakt weil er sehr intensiv
ist ansonsten auch sehr gerne die guten
alten vanilleschoten und wenn es gar
nicht anders geht dann geht auch
vanillezucker die alge masse wird noch
schnell klümpchen frei verrührt damit
sie auch vorbereitet ist und wir sie
anschließend in die milch geben können
die milch im topf lasse ich unter
ständigem rühren aufkochen so garantiert
ihr dass euch der topfboden nicht
anbrennt und sobald das ganze langsam
hoch steigt gibt ja auch schon die alge
mischung mit hinein und rührt das ganze
sofort um
[Musik]
nachdem das ganze dann einmal
vollständig aufgekocht ist schalten mit
dem herd runter hören was noch mal
fleißig um und geben das an die seite
der pudding darf jetzt etwa fünf bis
acht minuten ausdampfen aber ihr müsst
dabei ständig umrühren damit sich keine
haut bildet nun habe ich mir den ersten
bizkit boden bereit gelegt den bug
rahmen drum herum gegeben und gebe jetzt
den warmen beziehungsweise heißen
pudding darauf
auch hier nochmal der hinweis ihr
braucht den bug raum nicht unbedingt ihr
könnt das ganze auch ohne einfach
verstreichen und schichten und
anschließend die unschöne ränder einfach
gerade abschneiden
nachdem der pudding ganz schön glatt
gestrichen wurde kommt der zweite bizkit
boden darüber
damit wir mit der nächsten schicht
weitermachen können muss der kuchen
komplett ausgekühlt sein dh kein warmer
vanillepudding darf mehr durchdringen
denn sonst würde uns die marshmallows
schicht schmelzen dann darf auch schon
die weiße marshmallows schicht darüber
gegeben werden und wird auch glatt
verstrichen und man muss sich
zusammenreißen denn die ist unglaublich
lecker und mein persönlicher favorit
und falls sich der ein oder andere jetzt
gerade wundert was denn das für zwei
mäuse im hintergrund sind die euch an
lächeln
die idee stammt tatsächlich von einer
kleinen konditorei im ruhrgebiet nämlich
genauer gesagt in essen und die
verkaufen diese mäuse und die ist
genauso geschichtet wie unser
blechkuchen und da viele zuschauer eben
genau diese mäuse so sehr lieben habe
ich mit diesen blechkuchen dafür
ausgedacht
der kuchen kommt jetzt für eine stunde
in den kühlschrank damit die schicht
schön fest werden kann
in der zwischenzeit machen wir die
glasur fertig dafür benötigen wir voll
mit kuvertüre zartbitter kuvertüre und
ein wenig kokosfett dafür benötigen wir
erneut ein wasserbad ich habe mir das
wasser in einem topf aufkochen lassen
gebe eine schüssel darüber und gäbe dann
die voll mit kuvertüre hinein
nach wenigen minuten ist die kuvertüre
geschmolzen dann ruhig das einmal um und
dann kommen die tat bitter kuvertüre mit
hinein
[Musik]
damit die schokolade nicht zu sehr
bricht beim anschnitt geben wir an der
stelle auch noch kokosfett 1
das könnt ihr auch gerne durch butter
ersetzen ich schreibe euch dann die
mengenangaben ganz genau in die infobox
[Musik]
sobald also die walze creme im
kühlschrank schön fest geworden ist
können wir dann gleich so darüber geben
und das ganze schön verteilen
[Musik]
dadurch dass wir die kuvertüre vorher
temperiert haben hat sie keine unschönen
grauschleier und glänzt wunderschön
nun fehlen nun noch die schokostreusel
und ja ich gebe zu normalerweise sind es
zart peter schokostreusel aber die gab
es im supermarkt nicht und ich finde
dass die vollmilch schokostreusel auch
super lecker schmecken
[Musik]
nun lassen wir nun noch die
schokoladenglasur trocknen und dann ist
der kuchen auch schon sehr wir bereit
ich muss zugeben ich bin total überzeugt
davon dass er genauso gut schmeckt wie
die maus und wenn ihr die
blindverkostung macht dann merkt ihr
auch keinen unterschied ich bin total
gespannt was ihr zu sagen habt und falls
ihr das ganze nach macht dann markiert
mich doch gerne wie immer auf instagram
mit dem hashtag hieß kitchen
falls euch dieses video gefallen hat
dann freue ich mich sehr wenn ihm einen
kanal kostenlos abonniert damit ihr auch
keines männer videos mehr verpasst
ansonsten danke ich euch das einschalten
und sagt bis zum nächsten mal auf dieses
kitchen